good morning John it is Tuesday April 28
and I have off the power cord for my
camera and I have very little battery
left so this is what I me happy very
quick video but I want this vide to be
roughly three minutes long in which I
will review ten books go lay miserab
can't believe it took me this long to
read this book and I haven't seen the
movie or the musical or anything I just
know like one of the songs but I think
it's safe to say that this one's gonna
be a classic decades even centuries from
now Hyperion
holy crap let's just say if you like the
way that you see the world and
experience the world don't read this one
because I think like 37 percent of the
people I know who are warped in their
mind are warped in their mind because of
this book Ursula lagoons powers trilogy
I loved Lagoon I am a lagoon fan I've
got a whole shelf of leg win over here
we Dennis see the world as it is and we
don't think of the world as it has been
or could be and when we do think about
that we don't think about the people who
inhabited those worlds and I think that
this trilogy does a really good job of
doing that helps me appreciate the
awesome of the world that I have but
still understand that amazing people
come from all circumstances and
situations this book is a joke book and
it sucks I bought it because I was
thinking about doing other jokes video
but the jokes that nerdfighters put in
comments are about eight hundred and
thirty six percent better than anything
in this book interworld not really your
typical Neil Gaiman here not as dark and
dirty but still fun and mysterious and
interesting it was meant originally to
be a TV series and I could definitely
see how it could have gone in that
direction written world this is actually
Ringworld throne this one kind of sucked
but the first one Ringworld was very
good if the complex and fascinating
engineering details of it all didn't
keep you captivated probably the sexy
enigmatic characters would but yeah
don't read any of the sequels not worth
the time the truth terry pratchett is
one of the greatest gifts the world has
ever given me I love you world thank you
for Terry Pratchett and the truth for a
journalist is like the best gift with
the finest wrapping paper and it's like
topped with little flowers made of rum
balls
yes moist von lipwig is at it again this
time taking on the journalistic
profession and telling the truth the way
only a con man can sorcery and Cecilia
which I've already given away adorable
book like a mix between Harry Potter and
Pride and Prejudice if only there were
zombies yes I'm kidding
too young
get caught up in a magical mystery
that's dangerous and dreadful and all
kinds of horrible things are happening
but what the story is really about it
those infuriating boys and marvelous
outfits and of course I had never until
last week read the Bermudez triangle Oh
Maureen Johnson how you've outdone
yourself I can't believe they wanted to
ban this it should be required reading
for everyone and going through high
school right now it's seriously like the
best portrayal of friendship and
sexuality that I have ever ever read
comes up and finally we have this is not
Tom yes that's right the New York Times
bestselling author of Paper Towns
Looking for Alaska and an abundance of
katherines is writing another book
and it's seeping out through riddles you
know books have riddles in them all the
time but riddles have never had books in
them before and that my friends is what
John Green is doing I needed to really
continue extremely exciting if you're
not following it it makes my head
explode every single week every week a
new riddle gets posted at youtube.com
slash is this Tom and as you follow the
sequence of riddles through you find the
story of this young girl on the run
without friends without anybody knowing
very little even about her own self and
of course if you get stuck this is not
forums comm is something I've started up
and so everybody's going there and
helping each other out with the riddles
when they get too hard cuz HMDA arms
Norgan arm if anyone else would like to
give short book reviews please do that
in the comments John you will see me
tomorrow